in the opening there are three things
you need to do you need to develop your
pieces to get the King to safety and you
need to fight for the central squares in
this particular example White has done
very well he's developed all the pieces
on the Kings side got the bishop the
knight and the rook into the game well
the other pieces the bishop and the
knight are ready to develop on good
solid central squares white also has a
lot of influence in the center on all of
these four central squares here here
here and here you can see that white has
influence over all of these squares with
the ponds the knight the rook the queen
and also the bishop which is attacking
this Knight that is fighting for this
important square right here let me show
you an example of a game I played a few
years ago in which both players make
good logical moves towards the center
this develops the night preparing for
castling and fights for two central
squares here and here so black does the
same essentially covering these two
squares and protecting the pond white
develops the bishop and now it's
prepared for castling while also
attacking the knight which is covering
these two important squares black
defends the pawn and prepares to develop
this bishop white castle's at the first
opportunity like develops another night
and attacks the pawn right here so why
it develops the rook while at the same
time protecting the pawn black develops
the bishop and relieves the pin on the
knight white moves another pawn into the
center which you can afford
since the pawn is attacked twice by the
knight and the pawn while it's also
protected twice by the knight and the
Queen and here we have a fairly standard
position this is called the Spanish
opening named after the Spanish priest
rui lopez who lived in the 16th century
this is one of the most popular openings
on every level from beginners to World
Championship matches the latest one
being Anand Carlson from 2013 in which
both I and my opponent are not employed
this opening with both colors